Now I know we're in
the technology age but
I don't want you to forget about
offline groups and events.
They're great ways to expand your user
base and to improve your branding or
if you do it right, generate some PR.
As for industry events, you can have
a booth at a relevant conference.
You could be active in meetups.
You could even host relevant events.
Now, if you have the resources,
hosting events is a great thing for
a few different reasons.
One, it can help you attract
talent to join your team.
Or it can help you find writers
to feature you in an article.
If you're a business to business or
B2B company, hosting events in a topic
that attracts your potential customers
is also a great way to gain users.